welcome to data via staff talk I'm your
host - khazi developer advocate for data
studio in this video we'll show you how
committee connectors work community
connectors are custom connectors and
built in app script that you can use to
connect your own data to build a
community connector you will develop
your coding app script and then deploy
the connector then users can start using
it based on different user actions in
data studio the data studio will execute
the script and invoke different
functions then based on the function
response data studio will take different
actions and render the interface as well
as the data on the screen in this video
we will show the community connector
flow step by step we will also show the
expected outcomes on screen and the user
interactions to help you understand how
to develop your code when you develop
your connector you will write the code
and also provide certain metadata about
your connector in the manifest the
manifest will be a file named Apps
Script JSON and it will be a part of
your Apps Script project we will discuss
the manifest in details in a later video
your code can be in a single file or
distributed across multiple files in
Apps Script for a basic community
connector you will need to define four
functions in your code the first
function is get hot type that tells data
studio the authorization type for the
connector the get config function tells
data studio how the user configuration
screen should be rendered then the get
schema function provides a schema for
your data
finally the get data function provides
the actual data for the requested fields
to data studio now let's see how a
typical connector workflow would look
like this is more of a simplistic
example to better illustrate how the
connector workflow works depending on
your implementation and requirements
this workflow might press somewhat vary
to use a connector the user first
selects it in data studio in our example
we are showing the google fit connector
that lets you fetch your google fit data
once the user has selected the connector
data studio now executes the connector
script and calls the get off type for
based on the response provided by the
connector data studio will then trigger
the required authorization flow the user
will see the oxalá on the screen and
complete it to provide authorization to
the connector for our example only the
Google authorization is needed for the
connector for your implementation you
might need additional authorization from
a third party site after the
authorization is complete data studio
will call the gate config function from
the script in this function you can
define what configuration information
you'd like to collect from the user
based on the response from the stripped
data studio will render the
configurations interface for the
connector here we can see that the
Google fit connector needs only one
configuration input from the user
it asks the user which type of data it
should return the user completes all the
necessary configuration and clicks
connect at this point data studio has
the necessary configuration and calls
the get schema function to get the
schema of the data it will render the
field screen and let the user update the
schema if needed in our example we can
see that for the selected configuration
the Google feed connector has a schema
with five different fields the user
picks the create report button to move
on to the next step now the user will be
shown a blank data studio dashboard
where they can add charts and tables to
create their own report when the user
adds a new chart data studio will make
the get data call to the connector
script the connector will then fetch the
data from the Google feed API and send
it back to data studio then data studio
will render the chart with the data this
is basically how a community connector
works our example showed a full workload
from authorization to rendering the data
now if I shared the Google feed
dashboard with someone else
and they view the dashboard data studio
will only make the get data calls to the
connector to refresh and update the data
so when a dashboard is viewed only the
get data calls will get executed so that
was an overview of how communicators
work in data studio in our next videos
we will show you step by step how you
can build your own connector you can
always go to
developer site at developers.google.com
slash data studio for more information
if you enjoyed this video like and
subscribe to the GCP channel for more
videos like this thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]